marriage is so complex it is so complex
it's so complicated can you imagine you
got
one person who already doesn't get along
with themselves all the time you
me decides to team up with another
person
and then they decide to put a ring
together full-on commitment
and on top of that now they don't get
along with each other and they don't get
along with themselves
they decide to have kids and maybe two
of them
if they're crazy maybe three or more
then comes the in-laws then
each of them have aspirations he has his
own idea what life and success looks
like
she has her own maybe they share common
values and principles
and then they live and watch what
happens with this
okay so let me paint a picture for you
imagine you're someone who's married
and you want to do something big in your
life
and you're determined you're like i have
to go make xyz happen in my life you're
ambitious
and that's going to require a certain
level of focus and determination and
sacrifice or whatever you need to do
but your family is not with it so then
it comes to a moment you gotta have a
conversation with your wife or your
husband
and you sit there and you say i want to
be an entrepreneur
she has no desire you want to be an
entrepreneur
he has no desire so let's first
make the one move which is what
you know what okay babe you're right we
have an okay life
why should i give everything i got why
should i pursue my dreams
why should i pursue our dreams for our
kids why
your family's putting a lot of pressure
on me you're putting a lot of pressure
on me my parents are putting a lot of
pressure on me
maybe the right thing to do is to
conform and make you happy
make my parents happy and make your
parents happy
and my kids have no clue what happy
means but they just want to see more of
me
so maybe make them happy okay
i think i made the right choice my
pastor would probably tell me to do
something like that
and i go with it say at the time when i
do that i'm 40 years old
so i'm 25 years old
10 years goes by 20 years go by
30 years go by
i'm in a similar situation life is
boring
i made the safe decision i made
everybody happy
except for one person now i'm 65.
and in my mind the number one enemy in
my life is who
the person that prevented me from
pursuing my dreams and aspirations that
i had
and who's that enemy my wife
or my husband or my parents or your
parents
or a little bit of the kids helped me
back from pursuing my aspirations
so then there's a dinner and you're 70
years old
and everyone's sitting around the dinner
and everyone's having conversations
together
okay and you're sitting about yourself
and you're a little bit bitter you're a
little bit upset
you're not saying anything somebody
comes up to you and says grandpa
grandma what's up you look upset you
look angry
in your mind you're saying if i would
have pursued my dreams
god knows where i would have been today
and you're bitter
do you think you're really going to tell
your grandkids or your kids what you're
upset about
i don't think so so now you may say well
pat
what are you saying is the solution
leaving my wife
leaving my husband should i get a
divorce is that what you're endorsing
no it's not what i'm endorsing so what
are you saying here's what i'm saying
i'm saying have the tough conversation
what do you mean by the tough
conversation
let me break it down for you here's a
tough conversation
babe we need to have a talk when
saturday night or friday night
we need to get a babysitter i need six
hours of your time because we need to
have a serious conversation
i don't want any interruptions i don't
want any kid on interruptions i don't
want your parents my parents nobody
just you and i okay babe what's going on
is everything okay
everything's okay we just need a serious
conversation or maybe if you don't have
kids you got to get away
you leave saturday night spend sunday
and ask some questions
what's the question sound like here's
what the question sounds like i'll give
you the formula
babe what is your dream life look like
what do you mean babe what does your
dream life look like what do you see
what do you want to be next 5 10 15 20
years
babe i mean i just want to be with you
no no i know babe but what are your
dream what's what's your dream life
um you know i don't know i kind of would
be okay if we just have a
i said no you what is your dream who do
you want to be
well i kind of would want to have an
okay life and as long as i can
contribute
okay so that's what you want to do yeah
where do you want
the kids to be somebody division on our
kids
how do you visualize our kids you want
them to go to private school
you want them to have big aspirations
you don't to be just regular people
working nine to five
or do you aspire to see your kids one
day running a business being a ceo doing
something big running for office i don't
know what do you want to see your kids
do one day
do you want to paint a big picture for
our kids or a small picture for our kids
i don't know babe i just want them to be
good citizens
okay how about us babe so this is you
this is kids how about us where do you
want us to be together
babe this is really scaring me where
we're going with this no babe i just
want to know what do you want to be
who are we going to be i just want us to
be a regular
happily married couple et cetera et
cetera
what about you babe where you going with
this where do you want to be babe let me
tell you where i want to be
here's where i want to be and this is
what i'm struggling with right now this
is my dreams
this is my aspirations i want us to be
here
i want the kids to see a big life i want
them to pursue their dreams
i don't want to have my parents life i
love them they did great things for me
you have no idea how much i love them
but i want to make them proud and i want
to take this thing to a whole different
level
and i'm struggling right now what are
you struggling with i'm struggling
between compromising to want to
live a small life and later on being
bitter at you and upset at you because
you held me back when my parents helped
me back
versus having a serious conversation
with you and saying babe why don't we go
for it and put a timeline
give me five years give me a 10 year run
rate i'll make you proud
and here's what i want to do and if we
do this together
i'll take the lead you tell me who you
want to be let's decide what we can do
for the kids so they can have a big life
here's who we can be and we can make our
parents proud
what do you think about that babe it's a
little scary i know babe but
i love you i want to be with you i want
to build a strong family
i just don't want to live a small life i
don't
do you realize how tough it is to have
that conversation with your spouse
do you know how many grown men i know in
their 40s 50s that have never had this
conversation with their spouse
do you know how many women i have that
i've worked with
that have massive aspirations they can't
have this conversation they're afraid
so you know what they do the first
position i talk to you about which is
what
you know what i'll just do what they
want me to do and i'll conform
years ago my wife said i said wait
what's going on i said babe i i
i've always wanted to be a poet really
yeah okay i asked you what do you want
to be we had this conversation years ago
why don't you take a poetry class and
see where this can go you're serious
yeah seriously yeah i went online and i
looked up the best poetry class in l.a
it was ucla found the professor i said
here here it is
seriously she took night classes to go
see if she wants to be a poet you know
what happened
she wrote a bunch of nice poetry never
pursued it again but she got it out of
her system
then we had kids babe do you want to be
a stay home
do you want to be a courier woman do you
want to have an identity what do you
want to do
i kind of want to do both i want to be a
mother that knows everything about my
kids i want to nurse my kids i don't
want to have it
she's nursed every single one of the
kids she knows every single time she did
it for all three of them and she nursed
them for 9 to 12 months
that was important to her but she still
was at the office because she wanted a
curry because she wanted her own
identity
because we talked what do you want
and i told her what i want and i painted
a picture what kind of a thing i want to
see i don't want to have our kids see
and who we can be now do i know for a
fact that marriage is going to be
complex and difficult
it's the most difficult thing i've done
in my life i've been married 11 years
and the way i take marriage is one year
at a time
i don't sit there and say oh we're going
to be married the rest of our lives why
put that kind of pressure
one year at a time and you keep trying
to improve and improve both people are
going to change how do you know you
can't predict the future
you can control you and improve it
the reason why i'm having this
conversation with you is because
if you do choose to live option number
one
ever wonder why so many people say
grumpy old men what are they grumpy
about
you ever wonder why they say grumpy old
man what are you grumpy about
we've never done research why are grumpy
old men grumpy
you don't think a part of it has to do
that they're 78 years old thinking they
could have made a different decision at
32 but they were afraid and they didn't
you don't think that's a part of it you
don't think when they were 20 they said
i could have teed it up and done
something big with my life
i compromised my dreams and now they're
bitter to everybody it's not
anybody else's fault it's not your
wife's fault it's not your husband's
fault
you didn't have the guts to have that
conversation with your husband or wife
it ain't on your parents or your wife or
your your in-laws it's you
don't blame the kids don't blame the
wife don't blame the husband don't blame
your parents
blame your courage you should have had
that conversation
nobody to point fingers too but you sit
down
have the talk or forget about it
but you can't do one or the other you're
going to be miserable
so now you're watching this
i wasn't expecting a video like this
from you today pat this is supposed to
be motivation monday i'm quite frankly
not motivated
not trying to motivate you i'm trying to
challenge you today
to have the tough conversations and if
you're single you're like dude i don't
even know what the hell this guy's
talking about i'm not even married
this doesn't apply to share it with
somebody that's married but if you're
married with kids i know
you know exactly what i'm talking about
you know it
yes you know it you know it there you go
have the conversation how old are you
right now
how quickly did the last five years go
by
[Music]
how quickly did the last 10 years go by
do you realize how quickly the next 10
is going to go by
like this 20 i'm 41 i look right here
my age this is my age i look 28 when i
look at my hands like this
i look 41 right here i am aging look at
this
look at this i'm 41 you're aging
simple combo today have the conversation
oh and by the way i got a book
recommendation for you
if you've never read the book no more mr
nice guy i think it's time you go read
this book
no more mr nice i'm not the author i
don't make money off of it you can buy
it anywhere you want
it'll change your life and on top of
that
if you really want to reach your full
potential
and you want to be challenged even more
go watch this video
if you don't don't go watch this video
because it's going to challenge even
more
having said that have a wonderful week
this week